welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division is marvel's first
official disney plus series coming this
december
following scarlet witch envisioned after
the events of avengers end game and
infinity war in a conceptually ambitious
and
hugely influential story that could set
up the mcu
with x-men and the devil there are a ton
of details hidden in the visuals and the
music that are easy to overlook in this
trailer so i'm gonna break it all down
explain what we're looking at here and
how all of this like what lies beyond
vision's eyes is really a soulless
horror hellscape spoiler warning in case
i predict anything too accurately let's
get started
this trailer opens in the simulated
reality of a classic tv sitcom
with a curved letterbox aspect ratio and
static
fading into wanda maximoff envision as
newlyweds arriving in a 50s suburb
they pass a town welcome sign that's cut
off but notice vision's newspaper
west view herald little baby june's
first word tickles mother sue
so this town is called west view and
like a tv set it is
fake a simulated reality like sea haven
in the truman show
or the matrix in real life in the movie
the matrix in the comics scarlet witch
actually has the ability to
warp all of reality and in the house of
m comics a heartbroken wanda tries to
reset reality into a world where she has
a happy family here
wanda is warping reality so that vision
is alive once more
but her reality warping appears to be
contained
within this small town in which i
believe she is actually being
manipulated by nefarious entities
the witch agatha working on behalf of
marvel's devil mephisto
the two of them trapping wanda inside
her own dream bubble
that's really a portal to hell i believe
agatha is brainwashing wanda
in this illusion using tv sitcom
reference points
to try to keep wanda's mind calm and
vulnerable
this whole 50 setting with vision evokes
the 2015 tom king vision series
which reconceived vision in a similar
atomic age now wanda's sorcery powers in
the comics all come from her being
marked by the elder god chathan when she
was a baby which allowed her to be able
to use and manipulate what's called
chaos magic i think the chaos magic is
what agatha and mephisto
want notice vision and wanda's license
plate reads zero one zero two
maybe an odd to avengers issue 102 in
the 70s when vision gets an
offer from the grim reaper to have his
consciousness transferred to the body of
wonder man so that vision could be
closer to his love scarlet witch
but in this show i believe wanda has
made a similar
deal with the devil mephisto who get
vision
back in her life and it is agatha who
helps wanda manifest this
happy home reality via chaos magic but
probably has plans to hijack that magic
for a darker agenda the music we're
hearing is the platters 1958 love ballad
twilight time
with lyrics about a couple finally
embracing after a long day apart
at twilight the magic hour a surreal
time of day where the light hits
everything strangely
and it's kind of hard to tell when
exactly it is you're lost in time but
in this song you're with your love and
this is what reality looks like for
wanda envisioned in the show but the
darker
subtext of the song is the way those
surreal qualities of twilight time
can really lead to misperceptions and
illusions
lies this same song was actually is one
of my favorite episodes of x-files
season five's kill switch in which
mulder and scully discover a cd
remember those containing this same song
and evidence of a deadly ai code
90s they get trapped in a virtual world
that as they escape
flickers out with a similar static
visual aesthetic
that wandavision is using and like
fellow marvel mutant legion from his
amazing alternate universe fx series
scarlet witch appears to be projecting a
false reality around herself
one that is actually a mind prison as
dark demonic forces posing as friends
try to manipulate her and
exploit her catherine han's characters
appear
in these realities a comic relief
neighbor like ethel and i love lucy
later on in the trailer a kimmy gibbler
type character and a full house reality
but this black and white set looks more
like the dick van dyke show the closed
captions here credit her as
agnes which i think is really just the
name of this false sitcom
incarnation of the character really i
think agnes is secretly an
amalgamation of agatha harkness
and since she appears to change along
with these sitcom realities i'm thinking
she's part of the illusion maybe even
the town name
of west view could correspond to agatha
being a wicked witch of the west trying
to exploit this poor young lady in this
whole dream world
wanda plays this role of a magical
housewife like the ones in sitcoms like
i dream of genie or the more likely
reference point bewitched now this
wine bottle is labeled maison du macri
branch for
house of contempt which i assume are all
french households some people out there
are mistranslating this as house of
misery that's not exactly right but
the house of and the m label from the
pre is almost certainly a reference to
house of
m house of m again is the marvel comic
story line really the best scarlet witch
arc
in which wanda coming out of the
avengers disa simple story line suffers
a psionic meltdown
in which she warps reality over and over
again trying to find a happy family life
all this resetting is so chaotic that
the avengers and the x-men actually plot
to
take her out but before they can she
flashes reality again
into an alternate house of m universe in
which all of society has
mutants in charge ruled by magneto
wolverine and the others realize this
reality is false and after a big fight
wanda famously says the words
no more mutants permanently resetting
the marvel world with all but a small
number of mutants
erased from existence the speculation
here is that one division could feature
a reversal of that moment
using wanda's mind to spawn mutants into
the mcu
by pulling a kind of lionel hutz no more
mutants
but check out this next clip our story i
think what my wife means to say is that
we moved for move from where
married when damn it why oh arthur
stop it stop it stop it stop it
so their reality is collapsing during
this dinner date in which arthur played
by fred malamed
and his wife played by deborah joe rupp
you might know her from that 70s show
asks just some basic background
questions that they don't have the
answers to it's a bit similar to that
moment in inception when she realizes
she's in a dream
so how did we end up here well we just
came from the uh
think about it ariadne how did you get
here
where are you right now
we're dreaming and as wanda and vision
are going through a similar moment their
perspective
widens corresponding to the widening of
the film
aspect ratio from that tv letterbox to
the more cinematic widescreen
and in this reverse montage there's some
creepy imagery if you go through it
frame by frame
like one frame of wanda at that table
smiling followed immediately by a frame
of her wide-eyed with her mouth hung
open and then followed by the table set
but
no one's sitting there as that kitchen
window shutter opens
where is everyone it's like the rapture
yes nothing does
make the heart stop quite like a mystery
void much like the blinking cursor on an
empty promo code field when you're
shopping online what savings are you
missing out on well fear no longer with
honey
thanks to honey for sponsoring this
video honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
promo codes and automatically tests them
when you're checking out it's basically
your online shopping sidekick watching
your six for the best possible deal you
get honey on your computer for free
in two easy clicks then when you're
checking out on one of its 30
000 supported websites honey pops up and
all you got to do is click
apply coupons and you wait in just a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
for that particular site if honey finds
a working code you will watch the prices
drop
recently i was shopping for an herb
garden planner for my little patio space
i found one on target.com and honey
saved me over 10
bucks i was gonna buy that planter
anyways but now i have a place to slowly
murder all my plants and my attempt to
apply gardening tips from elizabeth
olsen how does she do it anyway those of
you have already installed honey using
new rockstars link have found
over 375 thousand dollars in savings so
if you haven't used on it yet you got to
get in on this honey supports
all kinds of retailers from tech and
gaming sites to fashion brands to even
food delivery
it's simple if you have a computer honey
should be on it it's free and it works
with whatever browser you use
get honey for free today by going to
joinhoney.com
new rockstars that's
joinhoney.comrockstars so they know i
sent ya and thanks again to honey for
sponsoring today's video okay
then their world fades into technicolor
similar to the imagery we saw in
pleasantville
in which the idyllic 50 sitcom world
colorized to reflect characters
awakening into consciousness
that might be what we're seeing here in
one division these characters jumping
ahead through the decades of famous
sitcoms the 50s the 60s the 70s 80s 90s
until they get to the present
when the whole tv multicam sitcom is
used less and less as audiences want a
more
naturalistic single cam format
representing wanda's
surface awakening from that sitcom dream
vision wanted dance in what looks like a
70s brady bunch reality
and then they're holding babies in an
80s sitcom kind of like family ties or
full house which ironically featured
elizabeth olsen's twin sisters these
babies are almost certainly
wanda's twins later revealed to be billy
kaplan and tommy shepard evidenced by
that b
and the t on the refrigerator art in the
past teaser billy and tommy
are the mutants wiccan in speed members
of the young avengers that marvel
appears to be setting up with kate
bishop and the hawkeye series
cassie lang stature and ant-man 3 and
with jonathan majors playing kang the
conqueror in that movie kang's younger
alternate self
is the young avenger iron lad so yeah
this is definitely where they're going
a little detail i noticed here though
the baby vision holds has a red
glow emitting from his hand so this one
could be wicked with the chaos magic the
sorcery he inherited from his mother
now manifesting with a similar red glow
from the hands now one of these episodes
is set during halloween and
great detail here rwanda's scarlet witch
costume is like a costume store version
of the
classic bright red tierra cape that she
wears in the comics same thing with
vision he wears his classic
bright green bright yellow costume now
outside here vision floats high above
the town he's probably trying to get a
bird's eye view
of this fictitious dream world but
notice as he lifts off the surrounding
trick-or-treaters
are not moving something has gone wrong
with this projected reality that
lamplight is flickering like the tv
static
everything is frozen and also check out
this great moment when he floats back
down to talk to agatha
am i dead no why would you think that
because you are
interesting so notice that single tear
that drops out of agatha's eye the
moment vision touches her as if
awakening her from a trance to me this
suggests that agatha herself
is part of this manipulation rather than
the sole orchestrator of it
i don't think she's the only antagonist
here so i'm thinking she's in a trance
as a vessel maybe a surrogate
for nepisto in the comics wanda's
children do start out as
pieces of mephisto's soul that mephisto
and agatha use to manipulate wanda and
then sadly those kids are like
reabsorbed into his soul before they're
later
reborn as wicked in speed because comics
notice here vision's wearing a wedding
ring
so yes i don't think vision is just like
part of the illusion
he's confused he's a point of view
character so it looks like wanda's chaos
magic is being used to
make him alive and sentient once more
within this reality also this might be
nothing but our friend alessio on
twitter pointed out that the italian
translation of this moment in the
trailer
agatha's line because you are dead the
version of you that they use
is plural as if agatha is suggesting
both vision and maybe
wanda are dead that's why i think this
pocket reality is actually a hell mouth
a portal to the marvel underworld
where wanda has offered to trade her
soul so that she can be with vision
and their kids a deal with mephisto
through his surrogate agatha
making both wanda and vision in a way
dead and in a lighter note some doofus
wears a traffic cone on their head
and then we get a glimpse of wanda
mid-transition as she warps the living
room around her
the lamp the chair the painting they all
switch like a tv channel
and the tv statics from an old rabbit
ears set into a more modern one
but then perhaps the most explanatory
and important shot of the trailer
monica rambo an adult version played by
tiana paris aged up from the little girl
in captain marvel future
photon or spectrum she blasts back with
red chaos energy away from that town
out through a membrane of this dream
bubble that when punctured looks like an
old color tv screen
there's red and green and blue pixels
there and she flies back
past the west view welcome sign and
lands in a grassy field where you can
see
a government perimeter roadblocks towers
tents trucks a helicopter armed soldiers
and i believe this could be
sword an offshoot of shield sentient
world observation response department
which based on some set photos monica
rambo is speculated to
be a member of and if you look among
those agents who run up behind the
soldiers one of them
is darcy lewis from the thor movies who
is probably applying her astrophysics
knowledge to help sword now in the shot
that also kind of looks like monica
running up to the left of her maybe this
is taken from a different shot than the
part where monica lands in the grass
either way
i believe sword set up this perimeter
around wanda's world bubble maybe
hellmouth trying to
contain wanda from resetting the entire
world by accident and they send in
monica to try to infiltrate this world
in disguise in 70's attire but then she
gets repelled back out and yes i believe
these government forces will also be how
agent jimmy wu ties into this plot
the trailer ends here we are an unusual
couple you know
oh i don't think that was ever in
question i cannot stop thinking about
vision's necktie what kind of design is
that
there's like these two fiery bursts
inside of a rectangle two diamonds on
the outside looking in
maybe the two souls burning in this hell
mouth prison
trapped there by two demonic presences
or maybe
two gem powered avenger parents gazing
in
at the twins there that are actually
hell babies in a death trap
look there's a lot to talk about and
this week's rogue theory will actually
explore the different ways vision could
have resurrected be sure to check it out
and you can discuss these marvel
theories with me on new rockstar's
official discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstars subscribe
to new rockstars and hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
at evos follow new rockstars thanks for
watching
boom
[Music]
you